you authored the textbook titled
evolutionary psychology the new science
of mind in its uh sixth edition
what is the magic ingredient that gave
birth to homo sapiens
do you think is it fire cooking
ability to collaborate
share ideas ability to contemplate our
own mortality
all that kind of thing yeah well i think
it's hard to isolate one factor i know
uh i know you've had richard wrangham on
this podcast it was a wonderful
wonderful interview and
uh he used to be a colleague of mine
when i was a professor at michigan and
um i've stayed in touch with him uh on
off he's a brilliant brilliant guy and
he thinks uh fire and cooking have been
one of the key
things but i think it's hard to isolate
um i would trace at least part of our
uniqueness to
uh the uniqueness of our mating system
so we have in in mating
uh unlike chimpanzees who are our
closest primate relative and of which
richard wrangham is is a world's expert
but they have basically no long-term
purebonded mating okay they female comes
into estrus
all the mating all the sex happens most
of the sex happens during that window
but humans have evolved long-term pure
bonded mating
uh and it's it's only one mating
strategy but it's a really important one
and then you have with that
male parental care so basically again we
go back to chimps and chimps
with whom we share more than 98 of our
dna
males don't do anything so they
inseminate the females but then when the
kids are born they basically don't do
much of anything in terms of
provisioning and so forth but human
males do we invest in the modern
environment could be decades you know
especially with the boomerang kids and
everything but
we're
not all males do
but compared to
the vast majority of mammals we are a
very heavy
male parental
investment species could you uh if it's
okay and i'll ask you a bunch of dumb
basic questions
because those are fun uh could you
define mating here how we is mating
refer to the
the the series of sexual acts
that lead to reproduction is it include
like dating and love and camaraderie
uh
loyalty all those things yes uh i you
know yes yeah yeah when i first started
studying yeah i don't it's when i first
started studying it i looked for the
right
term and
obviously it's much broader than sex so
by mating i include
things like mate selection
uh mate preferences made attraction mate
retention mate poaching um made
expulsion made poaching that sounds fun
so the early the uh the game theoretics
strategy made selection is primary what
mating what meeting is about or do you
include
the long term
once uh you agree
that you're gonna stick this out for a
while and have multiple children is that
also amazing yes i include that as well
so it's it's it's a broad category broad
definition and and absolutely includes
the emotion of love um and
of course there are many different types
of love brotherly love love parents
for children
uh but love i think uh and this is one
of the shifts in the social sciences so
when i was an undergraduate for example
i was taught that love is this um
invention by some caucasian european
poets a couple hundred years ago
and um and it turns out that's not the
case so you you there's been extensive
cross-cultural
evidence now that um that people not
every person in all cultures of course
but all some people in all cultures
experience this emotion that we call
love and for the word love
are we going to in this conversation try
to stick to sort of romantic love for
the the
for the meaning of the word love well
they're uh that's that's a great
question but um i mean they're
uh it's pretty well established that
there are these different phases of love
so there's this uh infatuation phase
where
uh our psychology we we get obsessional
thoughts it's hard to focus on work when
we're not with the person we're thinking
about the other person constantly uh so
there's kind of like ideal
ideational intrusion
into our psychology but you you can't
sustain that i mean it'd be
and then of course there's a uh
pardon the phrase but what i describe is
the [ __ ] like bunnies phase of of
this you know intense sexuality but
people have other adaptive problems they
have to solve
and so you can't stay in that state for
too long and so that subsides over time
and um
and develops into
at least in many cases this warm
attachment cuddling bunnies long-term
cuddling bunnies yes the face of the
relationship but still romantic not like
brotherly love or
you know because i i talk about a lot of
love a lot and for me
you know love is a broader
experience of just um
experiencing the joy
and the beauty of life so like just
looking out in nature yeah that's the
kind of love like whatever the chemicals
that lead to a feeling that at least
echoes the same kind of feeling that you
get with romantic love you can
experience that with even inanimate
objects that sounds weird to say but
just
a gratitude and appreciation
um
not in some kind of uh weird zen way but
just in a very human way just it feels
good to be alive kind of yeah yeah yeah
i guess i i would i mean that's an
interesting thought i hadn't thought
about
that i guess there i would use other
terms to describe
that so like the term ah
for example when you see a beautiful
sunset you know that's why i kind of
started out by saying i think there are
different types of love and i'm focusing
on the mating type and we'll talk about
that but so yeah there is a sense of
beauty
and there's a sense of
sexual appeal maybe that's a good and
those intersect in fascinating ways
we'll we'll talk about that okay we'll
talk about all of that but you're saying
mating
strategies now that we've kind of
placed ourselves what we mean by mating
mating strategies
is one of the cool features
that made humans what they are one of
the initial inventions is is the weird
uh weird and wonderful ways that we mate
yeah and
i mean if you go to
even things like um
how we compete for mates and this is
another kind of strange for some people
angle on it but
mating is inherently a competitive
process
in that desirable mates are in
secure supply relative to the numbers of
people who want them